good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
hump day you know it's a special day
here at the morning toast wednesdays
mean two things
three things actually one home day so
make sure to help someone you love
theo's almost always here on wednesday
so that's why it's special and
dear toasters so there's so much to be
excited about so much to be grateful for
for here on this wednesday we made it
through the storm it is now bright and
beautiful and a slight
chill breeze in new york this morning
the stormy vibe that passed through
yesterday was so crazy
and i was watching it from my window and
you could really feel at least in my
building i could feel
the wind because the wind speeds were so
high and what's so beautiful about new
york city is
all the trash that was in the street
just got swept up into the air and
there's
flying napkins and garbage and yeah
literally do you ever feel like a
palastic bag
floating through the wind like in the
middle of a hurricane yeah that's how i
felt yesterday it was super crazy but it
was also slightly anticlimactic the
hurricane lasted all of 30 minutes like
and it happened to have been the 30
minutes where i was outside
it was about two to three hours so fast
but i mean
it's pretty big for new york city and we
don't really get winds that strong here
so you really see how the city isn't
built for it or else maybe you know it
would
there wouldn't be trash in the streets
but um
it was it was crazy a lot of people lost
power they did
like yeah in new jersey like down the
street i had no idea
so um hope everyone's okay i hope
everyone's okay con ed like just
couldn't keep up
with the power they never can they never
can
it's always something with connie it's
always something with con ed
always and you know if you're ever
looking to blame someone for like
something it's always conan's fault
yes scapegoat i i totally agree so
um i hope everyone's doing okay
post-hurricane yes hope everyone is
safe at home safe at home and yes now it
is a beautiful day this storm has
passed and you know what the sky has
finally opened right the rain and wind
stopped blowing i was gonna sing a
different song but i like that one too
okay
i'll go the sky has finally opened
the rain and winds stopped blowing
but you're stuck out in the same old
storm again
storm again that sounds nice hold tight
to your
umbrella darling i'm just trying to tell
ya
that there's always been a rainbow
hanging over
[Music]
your head
it'll all be all right
i think that was beautiful i think that
sounded really good together i think
that if you were having this stressful
morning
that either just really [ __ ] bothered
you or
you know brought you some calm or we
were the rainbow in your day
you know that life is all about how you
see things i mean we hope to be the
rainbow in your day this show is the
rainbow in my day me too
for damn sure the show gives me
endorphins yeah there's also
there's really not much competition in
my day for things like to do
so this is my favorite part of my day
because it's literally the only time of
day
where i see other humans it's the only
part of day right it is the only day
you know i do understand i understand
that but no definitely saying good
morning millennials
is like um a power motto
and if you're ever needing to rev
yourself up for something like look in
the mirror do a power pose and say
good morning millennials you know the
power pose has largely been discredited
as like an
ineffective method psychologically and i
just want to let you know i've been
using the power pose for like the last
five years
and i think it is so beneficial and
there's no way it doesn't work like i am
living proof
that the power pose and its benefits are
real interesting
i haven't i didn't have like as much
success with it but i'm glad that
that you have it so works even if it's
placebo
getting yourself in that powerful kind
of position and like hiking yourself up
is
such a fabulous way to get yourself
together before meeting before a show
anything yeah i did once before asking
for a raise and i was just
a mess did you get the raise yeah i got
a teeny little raise
okay so it worked yeah effective i guess
but i think if i i don't know now all
i'm saying is like scientists like
because it was such a popular like
remember that woman who created like the
ted talk like went viral
and because it had like such um it made
such waves
when it was discredited like the
discreditation had to have made such big
waves and like scientists
were like all over it saying that it was
ineffective and like there's no proven
psychological connection
and i just i just don't buy it because
i'm living walking breathing
proof got it well i mean
what different strokes for different
folks totally that's and that's the kind
of science i subscribe to
me too my favorite kind of science um we
have
such a great show for you today
yesterday we recorded the redheads was a
really great episode and so i'm so
excited
to share that with you tomorrow last
night um i was so exhausted mentally
physically emotionally and spiritually
so i wanted to watch something like that
would be an upper
and i made the best choice of all time i
watch she's the man
lights off no phone and i
it was so amazing pure comedy it's the
funniest movie even when everything was
going down at the soccer game and like
they were about to expose sebastian i
was like
my hand was in the air like this like i
was like freaking out like i had never
seen it before yeah
it's just the best movie and i think
what makes it so good aside from the
obvious channing tatum amanda bynes like
i got a lifetime of knowledge my
favorite scooter is that it's loosely
based on a shakespearean story
right twelfth night and that gives the
movie so much gravitas like
all of the characters names the names of
the schools they heart back to
shakespearean times like
they go eat at cesario's like illyria
and cornwall are not what the schools
would have been named if it was just
like to all the boys i love
welcome to illyria welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome
to illyria
wow you made me actually really that is
i've never regretted sitting down
and watching that movie and when you
watch it you really realize
how many like popular phrases originated
in some form
i got a lifetime my knowledge from she's
the man
let the chips fall where they may bro
brother brethren there's so many she's
such a good actress
you know it's it's also slightly
devastating to watch the movie it is but
i was able to watch it like through the
lens of just
straight up appreciation i even watched
all of the credits because i was just
like who are these people involved in
this masterpiece
chew like you have a secret
it's literally such a good movie and
whatever happened to that girl who
played olivia she was like so cute she
was so cute i was thinking
about that for a lot of the characters
but i didn't recognize
um most of them in the credits so i
don't think they went very far fabulous
movie i could actually do an entire
episode on amanda mines and that movie
because it's
so good so good it's on hbo max and so
if you oh
and incredibly progressive here at
ileria we don't discriminate
based on gender so good
um it's on hbo max if you want to treat
yourself i bought hbo max yesterday
because i wanted you
told me to watch this episode of bill
maher and literally i couldn't find it
on youtube so i bought
a [ __ ] subscription i was getting so
[ __ ] frustrated
but like this clip i didn't even need to
watch the whole episode i needed to
watch his interview on bill maher
couldn't find it on youtube and
literally for this seven minute clip i
bought an hbo max subscription i did the
same thing and then last night i put it
to good use and so far i'm getting my
money's worth
now that i know that she's the man is on
there i will be keeping the subscription
past my seven day free trial i was
looking for a movie to watch for like 10
minutes and i just was like
i don't know what i want to watch but
i'll know it when i see it wait i'm
literally going home after this turning
the lights off and watching she's in
there and put your phone down like
absorb every element of it there was
like a brief
moment in history where she did like two
or three
absolutely sensational movies what a
girl wants
she's the man and what was the other
cindy white sydney white that's a
fabulous movie except the wig that she
wears
wig i don't understand it should have
been called sydney wig because
it's it's so obvious
yeah i didn't understand the reason for
the wig
it's so strange maybe it's not even a
wig it's like a toupee headpiece for her
hairline no like she wanted to cover her
ears the whole movie i don't know maybe
she had like ear surgery
right right that's the only thing that
that could possibly make sense yeah
yeah well i could literally talk about
amanda mines for hours but we digress
yeah we digress i just wanted to share
that with everyone in case anyone was
looking for an
a pick-me-up film that is so like i
don't even want to waste it because i
want to maybe hold on to it for when i'm
having a really bad day
not having a terrible day today you know
um i'm pleased with the way that
my my you makeup is very cute thank you
i'm like pleased with how everything
came out
i had a lovely time last night seeing
you and the redheads i met up with the
redheads after they recorded their
episode we had a nice
al fresco dinner and i'm feeling in high
spirits
yeah very high spirits so maybe i'll
hold on to the movie
um yeah hold on to the movie but you
never know where the date could take you
you know
truly if we roller coaster quarantine
we're not even in quarantine but like i
still refer to my life as quarantine
because i basically i am quarantined but
new york is in like phase 11 now
yeah we're just in like um a social and
economic depression
yes and emotional emotional mental
that's the social element spiritual
inside and outside we are depressed
actually you know what i take it back i
am actually not in a spiritual
depression i feel as though i've been
very connected to my spirituality
in these dark times because like when
you're feeling so low like what else is
there to do except cry before bed and
pray you know yeah
and pray gets better no literally like
all like and it's actually a nice
feeling when it's like literally things
can't get anywhere it's like what do i
do
let's say something to you i pray yeah
yeah so my spirits
to god have never been higher but my
spirits socially
pretty low pretty pretty low but that's
what we're here for to turn things
around for the day so
i guess we could get right into it if
there's not anything else we want to
cover
no you no i feel i feel covered so let's
get into the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
honey the best sponsor
ever made we all shop online and we've
all seen that promo code field taunt us
at checkout but thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past
honey is the free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds to your
cart
they support over 30 000 online stores
they range from sites that have tech and
gaming products to popular fashion
brands and even food
delivery i'm pretty sure like every
single toaster already knows and has
honey because they're the ones who told
us about it
and now that honey's sponsoring the show
it's just such a fabulous full circle
moment
um imagine you're shopping on one of
your favorite sites when you go to check
out the honey button drops down and all
you have to do is click apply
coupons within a few seconds honey will
search for coupons
that it can find for the website you are
shopping on and if honey finds a coupon
you'll watch the prices drop
um i've used it at sephora i've used it
uh bloomingdale's
literally every website and i wouldn't
normally forget to click the button but
it just pops down right in front of you
and they make it so easy and it's
literally like
a revolve it's literally free money
tulip
um honey yeah the tulip the code that
always populates on revolve it's
fabulous 15
yeah honey has found it's over 17
million members over two
billion dollars in savings if you don't
already have honey you could be missing
out on free
savings it's totally free and it
installs in seconds
by getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and if you use a link you'll be
able to support our podcast
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
toast that's join honey.com
toast for the free install uh
web browser extension it's just fabulous
you guys like i
i really feel like the ad speaks for
itself it does save money get honey also
if you are okay
that's a good um slogan i think we've
said that before but
i'm glad that you like save money get
honey if you're an investor like myself
and you're constantly investing
in items um honey just makes your
investments so much worthwhile
so worthwhile so worthwhile did you hear
to read on real housewives of beverly
hills yes i call it an investment when
they were shopping yeah she was
rationalizing to her ourselves she's
like it's an investment
no totally she was trying to get
garcelle to buy the 30 000 fur coat
yeah that coat was not worth that no not
at all
okay yeah i didn't think so for one
second no we knew there and i thought it
was gonna be like ten thousand dollars
yeah okay the first story of the day is
really the big news of the day that it's
very exciting kristen cavallari and ex
stephen coletti
reunite for a photo after her split from
jay cutler
so i'm sure the photo has been heard
around the world even though the quality
is
so blurry and dark um on tuesday she
shared a selfie of herself
cuddled up to stephen coletti on
instagram captioning it
2004 or 2020 it shows the two smiling
softly
i mean this obviously like for the pop
culture fanatic who we literally grew up
on laguna beach
and steve then and the hills like this
is so
unbelievably full circle and it's
beautiful even if you weren't team
kristin like we've evolved past that and
like it would be fabulous if these two
got together
but it really reminds me of um
kind of like morgan stewart now allow me
to okay
go on your journey go on my journey so
kristin cavallari i'm trying to remember
okay chris and cavalier and steven
cloudy obviously dated way before she
was married
in high school in high school but like
it was it was on tv so it was
it was her first love it was her first
love and
to go back to him at like immediately
aft i don't know if they're together but
like if they are together
to go back to him after um like
immediately getting divorced
it's like oh is jay cutler thinking like
oh my god was he thinking was kristen
kevin larry thinking about stephen
colletti the whole time we were married
and that's like now jordan is [ __ ] so
many names sorry
morgan stewart is engaged to jordan
mcgraw and a lot of people don't know
she actually dated jordan mcgraw before
brendan so it's like now she's back with
jordan mcgraw and it's like the guy she
told you not to worry about
yeah okay so do you see the parallel the
parallel but i just need to
add one comment because obviously i ship
so hard and this is beautiful
but justin anderson commented on her
post and he's her best friend and he
said oh lord here come the internet
rumors
you two haven't aged a day making it
seem like they're friends they caught up
and they posted this picture just to
[ __ ] with everyone but in no
world are they dating i don't know it's
just
in no world are they dating i i it's too
good to be true but also like
she is not the person that she was in
she was so annoying in 2000
and so i to me it's like too much time
has passed and it's just a fun novelty
thing at this point
when i saw it i didn't have like like my
ship wasn't coming into the port or
anything like everyone the port was
clear i wonder if i
like started watching laguna beach again
would i still be like so hard team elsie
like
i hated kristen cavalier because she was
just like
like showing up places like that she
wasn't meant to be at yeah
but now i feel like if i watch it like i
might be a christian stan
well watching it as a christian stan you
might just automatically start on
kristen's side but we all started on lc
side because she was the narrator and
like she was our girl
and it was her show and kristen was
getting in the way of her love story
yeah totally
um also i do think like kristen like has
her mean moments on the show and so
you can you might like those or you
might not like yeah
i remember i watched laguna beach within
the last five years i watched a few
episodes and what i realized was that
they're drunk the whole time wow like i
mean when i was growing up watching it
like yeah and they were drinking out of
red cups like i didn't know what i was
watching
but now like the way that they talk and
they're talk so slowly
blurred it's like oh they're just drunk
that's so interesting yeah but they're
so young
that like they're hiding that they're
drinking of course because they could
never do it on tv that's like even
siesta keys some of the kids weren't
even 21 until recently
um also do you have do you remember that
like spin-off show
newport beach yes that never really went
anywhere i
liked that me too and when the two
people kissed and they played bubbly by
colby calais
oh that's cute i mean those types of
shows used to be like literally like
a and r for me like if your song was on
that show like you made it
you know and they used to play like the
best like early 2000s like simple plan
type stuff it was fabulous
it was a a mixture of pop culture music
love it it was great for music discovery
that was a great day to be
a great time to be like a a kid yeah
like i'm i'm happy that that's when
that's the era we were in and i think
that like
when kids who are now that age like what
is their
taking on the beach that's what i was
getting and they get their music from
tick-tock
and they're people that they love to
follow from tick-tock i much prefer the
laguna beach childhood years over the
tick-tock years
yeah i think they're both good but i
liked i mean everything that was
poppin in pop culture when we were
growing up like we consumed
so heavily so hard we stand so hard like
we watch so much tv
we it was like really a golden age of
television reality television and we
were right there consuming it all and it
was like a disney channel
change for the world i wouldn't either
like the disney channel literally wasn't
like
i guess it was like a kids network but
there was like a few years where it was
like
hot teenagers before they got like a
little too old like hannah montana
selena gomez jonas brothers and that was
really like the golden years of disney
channel
and of our childhood yeah it was a good
time to grow up i'm not gonna lie
goodbye
it was a good good time
to be alive i have no regrets about
growing up in that time no i have no
regrets either
except you know when you were a kid like
going to a concert was such a big deal
like i think like
by the time i was 15 i maybe went to one
maybe two concerts because it was just
like
i don't know if it was like this for
everyone but it was like such a big deal
and it was so special and they were like
they never came to your town when they
did you'd like beg your parents and now
i just feel like kids go to concerts all
the time
no i still feel like for kids going to
concerts are a big deal because your
parents have to take you concerts can be
like really
there's so many people and it could be
dangerous no and you need to be
supervised
and so if your parents are taking you to
a concert and you also don't have your
own money like
you only get to go to the biggest and
best ones yeah they're not gonna take
you every week to a show well that was
the worst
jojo siwa not having the financial
freedom to make your own choices
yeah that's my favorite part about being
an adult yeah financial freedom is
fabulous you can get all the investments
that you want
yeah go to all the concerts and just use
honey and justify it yeah yeah yeah
um okay well i look forward to see where
these two go i mean i
i'm holding out hope you know i'm an
eternal optimist eternal
but that's not how i saw it when i saw
it yeah no
she's you know one she's wanting to
change her google search because right
now it's not in her favor
yeah and i think like maybe there was a
little high school reunion maybe they're
still friends there they grew up in the
same town maybe she's home and they saw
each other and they're like let's break
the internet today
why not why not you know give claudia
and jackie something to talk about thank
you by the way because it's been a dry
week out here
yeah okay next up such another cute love
story
tiffany haddish confirms her romance
with common she says i love him
oh my god you guys i love this so much
she ready
tiffany haddish has confirmed her
relationship with common the girls trip
star revealed the romance on stevo's
podcast wild ride
calling it quote the best relationship
i've ever been in this is hands down the
best relationship i've ever been in
knock on wood i've lost 20 pounds since
i've been in this relationship
that's when you know it's good where
you're so happy and you're so busy and
and entwined with the other person that
you actually forget to eat
or sorry on the other hand then you gain
it back
when you get into the comfort stage of
laying in bed right there's also a stage
where it's like you're so happy you
don't really care about what you look
like because somebody loves you so much
for you and like you're just
not thinking about things that you
normally would think about and you just
like eat to eat and you eat to live and
sometimes you gain weight and like you
don't really care
that comes eventually but in a new new
relationship
um i found that i'm just like so busy
and we're just doing things and we're
dating and
we're talking so much and we're not
eating the food on the date like i've
personally never experienced that but i
do have limited dating experience maybe
that's why
i just never lost weight because i was
so
happy when i started dating zach i had
just like
lost a good amount of weight but you
know i always have those last four
pounds and then like in the first
month that we started dating like i took
off those last four pounds and i was
just in like the best shape of my life
never experienced but it sounds nice
yeah it was it was exciting and now i'm
in
the worst shape of my life she continued
quote i feel more confident in me and
it's not him that's doing it i'm just
way happier and it's like knowing i got
somebody that cares about me
that really has my back it seems like he
does anyways and i love it i love him
stop by the way i never would have
paired these two together but
i think that common is such an eligible
bachelor and i thought so ever since he
was in my favorite movie just right with
queen latifah
such a good movie if you've never seen
it also very feel good um
and this is just like a a pairing i
didn't know that i needed and now that i
see it
and she really describes like how happy
they are together they have to get
married i'm sorry
yeah no hearing her describe how happy
they are together and also just i love
the idea of them and then knowing that
it is that good
is everything of the sort and i'm so
happy for them and i feel like
it's been a while i mean i guess we've
gotten some really good couples in the
queue
well so i was gonna say top of the list
this is a
quarantine couple that spending all this
time together has
helped instead of sorry kelly clarkson
hurt their relationship and for that
we need to be grateful to the queue yeah
they gave us tiffany haddish in common
like i can't
she said they've both been tested for
coven and are clear so quote
yeah we've been [ __ ] we gotta
i don't know if that's just so funny
because you said it or it's just
she's so funny and actually i loved her
netflix special she did you watch it
it was like good netflix special but the
best thing was that she broke the fourth
wall because like she was filming
in front of a live studio audience and
um
like her mic pack fell like down her
pants like from her
back of her jeans and she like literally
stopped the comedy show like
mid-show and they kept it in the special
where like someone had to come out and
fix her
her pants and she literally just kept
doing like improv stand up while there
was like a woman
rewiring her mic pack and it was very
funny and very impressive and i really
liked it oh that's so
interesting yeah it was good well this
is just great news
like beautiful news to start your day
you know
yeah and it's very rare that like
celebrities are this open
about a relationship in terms of like he
makes me feel like you never get that
right but also they had like popped up
together a few times um
in the last few months but not
confirming that they were in a
relationship right now
yeah like they uh came onto someone's
like zoom party and flaunted their
romance at quest love's instagram live
birthday celebration so i feel like i
was just like seeing like headlines but
not any confirmation so great
confirmation straight from her with all
the tea about how great it is is
fabulous
yeah she's like making single girls
jealous like she's describing exactly
what everyone wants
yeah totally beautiful okay next story
some exciting
news uh for the talkers tick tock star
addison ray
is launching item beauty makeup line uh
let's take a pause for the
sirens
okay sorry that was dramatic it did
drive the other way i just i didn't want
anyone to think they were getting pulled
over
totally the 19 year old tick tock star
announced on tuesday that she has
partnered with incubator company made by
collective
to launch her own makeup brand item
beauty the line will launch with six
pro products on august 11th including
eyeshadow
brightening powder brow definer lip oil
a contour duo and mascara
with addison serving as the company's
co-founder and chief innovation
officer i mean this is a conversation we
had last week with dixie and charlie
dimelio being the faces of
morphe 2. um and actually really like
this route for addison
i don't know i'm not like that familiar
there to know if like makeup is like an
integral part of her brand and like if
this should be
the first company that she launches but
regardless as an influencer and you only
really learn this until you've been
doing
it for a while it's so much better to
spend your time like investing in a
brand that you own as opposed to brands
who are just going to pay you
for your time because while that's great
money there's no like stability or
longevity in and you get canceled that
is gone in an instant so um
i think this is great i think whoever is
advising addison is doing a fabulous job
yeah i totally agree i think this is
great i think as far as like her makeup
um look goes i think her eyelashes are
kind of
iconic they're extremely long and she
always i think she
she's always wearing makeup like she has
like a light beat at all times and so i
i do think that this
makes sense and it's exciting
it's exciting it's fabulous um i wish
your success it is always exciting at
least
for me and for you to see like yes the
trajectory that
influencers go on and the choices that
they make like some
people become big influencers and then
they put out a song like right like what
do they want to do
yeah and so i i agree that i think
everything that addison has done has
been extremely shrewd
yeah in terms of business and i think
she has great advisors and also
i think she's just a a good girl who
knows what she likes and knows what she
wants and
is therefore it's easy to
merchandise yourself when you have a lot
of great things going on for you
and i think she's a good role model and
i think that that'll take her really far
and you're right like watching
especially on tick tock because it's
like breaking so many
like records in a lot of ways it's so
interesting to like
watch just like like this is like an
incubator like where can
how far can social media take people
this is the biggest app in the world
they have the biggest
platforms like it's just really cool and
interesting to see like what they do
and what they are successful at what
doesn't work out like it's just
very cool to watch and i enjoy reporting
on it because i find it fascinating yeah
i enjoy reporting on it too because it
is it is really fascinating i'm not in
love with the name of her company
me neither it doesn't feel super
personal what is it item beauty
i feel like it could have been called
pouty face
that is such a that's her thing yeah
yeah but maybe she wants it to be less
like
about her yeah and maybe she's just like
serving on the board of this
company right it's not she doesn't own
it right maybe they're paying her salary
right who knows very interesting i will
be following up on this story and maybe
even purchasing some products
doing a review oh maybe a beauty review
on our patreon
patreon.com slash your morning toast for
7.99 you become exclusive premium member
of the morning toast which means
you get five extra episodes from us a
month they are either podcast or vlitty
vlog video episodes sorry vladio um so
yeah that 799 gives you five extra
episodes and then it also gets you
access to our facebook group which is
the toast after dark
which is the premium group for facebook
toasters
and you guys the chili cook-off is
coming this month we have to wait
because we're all gonna be in a house
together
with a big kitchen super easy me versus
ben it's the chili cook-off
the biggest chili cook-off since the one
that jessica simpson performed at
we have really um big plans for
ourselves just because we are gonna be
on break so as we already mentioned
we're doing um
all of august remotely and on weekly
episodes just podcast because we're
going away
and that'll be like a really um good
time for us to invest in our patreon and
we have some fabulous ideas like the
chili cook-off
we are also going to be recreating our
favorite
um cake from cipriani we have found the
recipe and it's
very difficult yeah so we're going to
try and make it we're going to try and
make it and if you have ideas you can
pop them in the facebook group once you
remember so
it's really a fun moment and anyone can
join at patreon.com slash the morning
toast
it's never too late to become a patron
just like it's never too late to become
a redhead
and it's never too late to be a toaster
but if you're here you already are so
totally okay next story some big movie
news that i find quite interesting
mulan will skip theaters and premiere on
disney plus
i mean they're having so much success
with that like yeah but they
they had dropped some premieres on
disney plus but they were always saying
like mulan will be in theaters
right but now um in another major blow
to movie theaters disney announced mulan
will forgo it's planned
the i'm sorry and theatrical release
instead the movie will premiere on
disney plus on september 4th
for a rental price of 29.99
wow wait that's crazy that is crazy
sorry if you paid for a subscription you
still have to pay for the movie you know
what
i mean sure it would have been nice if
it came with your disney plus
subscription but they're making up the
cost of movie tickets like but is it
only available to purchase on disney
plus or can you also purchase it on
apple tv
i'm sure you'll be able to purchase it
on apple tv eventually maybe it's disney
plus
first maybe disney plus is a better
price like maybe
on apple tv it'll be 35 i mean that's
crazy for a movie but if you think about
it like you watch a movie with your
family and that's four people and this
is a family movie
right and a movie ticket is fifteen
dollars per person so
technically yeah but you're not getting
the experience and honestly i thought
they had such success with trolls
it wasn't on disney plus but it was like
straight to vod video
video right like i was trending on the
apple store because i literally with my
comedy special
um i did make it to number two overall
on movies and i did never get past
trolls like i never beat number one and
just like
as big as you are you can never beat the
influence of stormy webster no that's
not it and
it was a real metaphor for my career as
big as i get like i'll never beat the
trolls
oh my god it was really beautiful
actually and it was it was a humbling
moment
um but yeah by the way i don't know if i
mentioned this but i came out with a
comedy special
it's called disgraced queen and it is so
funny the reviews are in and they're
just absolutely sensational
and if you want to watch it um it's
called disgrace queen it's available
on amazon prime apple tv itunes a bunch
of places you can also stream
the audio like if you listen to this
podcast and you have a long car ride
coming up
you can listen to like the whole 75
minutes on spotify amazon music
apple music all the places so there's a
highlight on my instagram story
scroll with no job that's my instagram
there's a highlight called disgraced
queen and it has links to all the places
you can purchase and if you're
if you're an international toaster and
you're having trouble um i suggest using
uh the vimeo link because you can
purchase or rent for cheaper
on vimeo and it's just um according to
you know my international my huge
international following um it's a it's
it's a good product so
great love to see it spend the night you
know invite some friends over and have
some wine like i would add that to my
list of like she's the man
of something no i'm not even like
blowing smoke up your ass or whatever
um of things that are uppers content
uppers content uppers and it's so hard
to find i find myself maybe it's just
i'm like
very vulnerable in quarantine and like
my emotional state is like not at its
best but
i have a hard time watching movies or tv
shows that have like
some sort of like disruption do you know
what i mean it's like things are going
great in the movie
and then like something happens and like
plot twist you know i find it like very
hard to watch emotionally
yeah like i get real life anxiety from
stupid [ __ ] happening in movies
yeah so i can't watch tv anymore i feel
like that's all you do no but i only
watch tv that i've seen
like because it because i'm comfortable
but then you started watching the crown
and you liked that oh that's true that's
true and i still have two episodes left
but that's really the only thing i've
started in quarantine like until you
start yellowstone
yeah i'm gonna make you but i have a
feeling that's gonna be real
anxiety-inducing
i don't think so i think it's quite
mellowing like the bucolic-ness
of it it just trumps all okay okay well
here's more information on mulan it was
originally scheduled to open on march
27th
it was meant to be one of disney's major
theatrical releases for the year i
remember the studio mounted a lavish red
carpet premiere at the dolby but just
three days later
the cascade of industry closures caused
by kovid forced them to postpone mulan's
release to july 24th
then in late june as you know nothing
changed
disney pushed the film again to august
24th 21st before indefinitely removing
it from the calendar
so now they have settled on this disney
plus release and i actually think that
this is a great idea
i'm so excited to see this movie and
i think it's exactly the sort of content
that we need right now you know
yeah and they have the movie in the can
ready to go and
what's the point in continuing to push
it off but we're gonna wait another year
and see this movie
people like need stuff to watch and
honestly i think that
i don't know if this is an actual
statistic but
movies and tv shows that are being
released during quarantine are
definitely performing well
yeah like i know i think with my special
like i got way more
people watching than if it was a regular
summer
june tuesday you know what i mean yeah i
think i don't know i feel like in the
beginning that's how it was
now i'm not so sure and it's weird
because
some of like the netflix content i think
is doing really well like i don't think
tiger king would have been
anything of the sort without quarantine
right but then like other tv shows i
think are having like record low numbers
oh interesting you know you mean like
cable shows yeah
probably it's like the things that are
being filmed from home yeah
oh i mean of course yeah i can't even
when you wanted me to watch bill maher
his segments from home are actually very
very well done they obviously set up
like an hbo studio in his house
but the guests and zoom and the wi-fi
like
uh at the end of the episode jim carrey
was on and they kept
talking over each other and when you
talk over it mutes
so it was literally a silent interview
it was so frustrating
that's really frustrating and that's hbo
like come on
yeah that's that's rough but the segment
i made you watch which was the segment
with barry weiss which you guys should
watch
on cancel culture was fascinating it's
fascinating uh she's fabulous
fabulous i thought that the way that it
was done via zoom still was
was fine yeah no barry's connection was
good there was another guy whose
connection was not so good and
like it was really bothering me like i
can't uh that really triggers me like
it's the zoom content that's why i was
so nervous about like um virtual
reunions on bravo but
they didn't use zoom like they literally
sent everyone equipment and was like
a manual on how to do it and even the
first one which was atlanta was
very well done and it's gotten better
and better since so
i don't have a problem i don't take
umbrage with that but i have major
umbridge with like
these interview shows that like even um
watch dragon's live with
kiki palmer and gisele kiki palmer's
wi-fi was so bad
and it just it ruins it yeah i agree
but that's all that's all we got okay
fifth and final story big update on
something we've been talking a lot about
instagram launches tick tock competitor
reels today by the way my content is
like so over performing
they gave it to like a bunch of verified
people um
before to like bank content so that when
they rolled out to everyone there was
stuff for people to watch
and i just uploaded like a bunch of my
maybe my three of my best tick tocks
and i guess today it literally rolled
out because like they had like
50 views because the only people who
could see it are your fellow fellow
verified accounts
but it got rolled out to a bunch of
people and my videos are just truly
taking off and i've said it once i've
said it again i couldn't make it on tick
tock but i will
make it on reals like i will make it
okay you will hear
me cry i will make it okay you're going
to make it
thank you i'm excited i had like but i
didn't post anything
maybe she should i know i feel like like
they're definitely probably like
um pushing that content it can be just
like a great growth moment i think
okay you had a good um you read a great
tick tock once
that was like how you edited this photo
to have this guy oh i should you should
just stop that video because that's what
people like you are a lifestyle but
you're really like
here you're like the behind the scenes
lifestyle like here's how
i do this you know like here's what it
looks like but here's what's going on in
the background
right and that was a and i actually used
that technique it was very helpful okay
i'm gonna post that video
and you should make more like that okay
cool i'll show you guys how i edit my
photos
right oh and then you also have a
product so that's like so your brand
that is so my brand you're so right
jackyoflow.com get your summer presets
y'all i mean
if you're literally uploading a picture
without presets like you're an actual
beast like it's just it's disgusting
it's it's not great it's it's bad it's
just so simple to add a preset to it you
know even like ben
is just now like out of control and he
also got his sister maddie
and they're sending each other pictures
of how to lightroom because ben cannot
figure out for the life yeah then just
text me his photos and
i send them right but everyone's on the
flow you guys everyone's on the jackie
flow
okay the app's one billion users on
instagram can now shoot edit and post 15
second video clips
they need to make that up to a minute in
order to fully compete with tick tock
15 seconds is way too short we've always
been able like for
the longest time they already did this
when they rolled out instagram videos
versus 15 seconds and people like it was
too long and too short at the same time
and then eventually they made it one
minute but by then like
it was videos like was just nothing of
the sort it really should have been
30 seconds yeah but they have launched
their new video feature called
reels as it looks to take on the fast
growing upstart tick tock
the feature which instagram tested for
months in countries including brazil and
india
allows users to shoot edit and post 15
second video clips
set to snippets of music or audio the
videos can be viewed via
a new portal on instagram's explore page
which curates and personalizes posts
based on a user's preferences oh i guess
that's why my videos got
a ton of views because it was on the
explore page yeah interesting no i think
it's good um
the interface itself is not my favorite
and i'm still
pretty much just making the content on
tik tok and uploading it to story just
like to really
do with snapchat yeah because i can't
figure it out yet and it's not that user
friendly like you can't
add music to one segment but not the
other it's just it's not there yet
so i think it'll get there but um i'm
not actually using the interface right
now can you post on reels without it
going into your
feed okay so that was my question i'm
pretty sure when you post on wheels it
goes to like your timeline
but on your profile it's not on your
grid okay okay
that's good there's a separate thing
right next to your grid that is now your
reels yes like where igtv
has been buried yes exactly it's a
burial ground for all of tick tocks
all of instagram's bad stolen ideas but
we'll see i'm excited honestly this is
very exciting i'm excited too it sounds
like a solution to the prop
to a problem hair in my yes well it
definitely sounds like a solution to my
problem which is not being able to make
it on tick tock
yeah but you were doing well like it
wasn't that no 80 000
is pretty good i'm actually at 90 but
it's
what's upsetting is like how much time
and effort i put into it like for that
result
and it's no like tic tac was known why
people loved it so much it was like
anyone can do it and anyone can go viral
and a viral video can literally you can
build a brand around it
so it's like i did have a few viral
videos and it's just like it never got
to the place where i needed to which was
like 500 000 followers
yeah i mean reals i'm here
i'm ready she's ready she's ready okay
wednesday means dear toasters which is
becoming the best part of my week
dear toasters is our advice segment if
you ever want to write in we will always
keep it anonymous and the email account
is dear toasters
gmail.com again deartoasters gmail.com
you can write in about anything
we'll always keep it anonymous and it's
great so let's do it i'm excited i
by the way i don't read them before
because like last week's was so good and
i had not read it
yeah no it's important dear claude and
jack how you doing
good i need advice my fiance and i have
been together for seven years since we
met in college
i've always wanted to get married in
saint thomas because it was my family's
favorite vacation spot growing up
before me and my boyfriend got engaged i
talked to my best friend all about my
dream wedding and st
thomas oh i know where this is going my
best friend has been dating
her boyfriend for only a year and they
got engaged one month before we did
after she got engaged she told me she
was planning a wedding in saint thomas
this was so annoying considering that
neither her or her fiance have ever even
been to saint thomas my best people are
shameless
oh this is annoying my best friend has a
lot more money than i do and is
planning on having her wedding at the
best five-star resort in st thomas a
month after mine
i've never been jealous or competitive
with my friends but i can help feel like
she's
i can't help but feel like she stole my
wedding and is just now gonna do it
better
i feel like such a brat to be even upset
about this but it can't help how i'm
feeling
should i change my wedding location talk
to my friend about how upset i am or
just
get over it sincerely a hurt friend a
hurt friend
you have a legitimate gripe this is and
you know what i went through something
similar
this is strange it's weird to choose a
location
to make they've crossover to make all
these people go back to saint thomas
again
and that they've never been to honestly
like for me this is so this is so weird
and it's it's also so you could make
like if you said something to her like
you could also sound crazy even though
like
in my heart like i know that this is so
weird and i'm understanding exactly how
you feel
it's and you're not crazy
uncategorically weird and
you know what would be the best case
scenario for this girl is if the bride
who's planning the wedding in st
thomas is a toaster and she's like
feeling like this story could be about
her
and i want you to know like the girl who
copied the idea like this is really
really weird of you
and i think you should move your
location yeah but
also when are these weddings supposed to
be are they even going to happen maybe
you push yours up i don't know
like maybe you could use covid like as
an excuse to sort of like
re-organize your plans yeah but like
it's been this girl's dream like she
shouldn't have to move no but like
but you know what at the end of the day
really like a wedding is really not
about how much money you spend like it's
so much i've been to some
[ __ ] expensive weddings that were
boring as hell and i've been to some
recently
priced weddings that were so much more
fun like it's really about the people
and the couple and the music and the
alcohol so like that's really it nobody
cares about your [ __ ] centerpieces
like it's such a waste of money so
i wouldn't worry her wedding first yes
okay i think the first wedding
like people for the second wedding it's
like oh we have to go back and if the
other girl's wedding was first i would
say
that would be much worse especially if
she's gonna have it like bigger than
yours right
um but since you're the first wedding
like you'll it'll be the better wedding
and maybe people won't even go back
for the second one but honestly like if
i had a
friend it's just like such an a specific
thing you know so yes so if this if i
had a friend honestly
who wasn't i don't know how close they
are like if it was a best best friend
like
i think i maybe would feel comfortable
saying something but it was just like a
friend
who is a decent friend i don't know i
think i would like
really re-evaluate my friendship with
them i mean i
just can't stand a copycat same who
who doesn't acknowledge it overt about
it by the way also
it's one thing like if you can own the
fact that you don't really have creative
ideas and like you're saying
like i'm gonna steal this from you
that's pretty admirable in a sense like
not everyone's gonna have the best ideas
but if you're gonna
steal something and pretend like it's
your own like that is the true crime
right and also to steal something so
personal like i understand if you
you know you don't have great taste so
this person gets a bag you get the bag
this person gets this coat you get the
coat
but for something so personal like a
wedding to steal really someone's idea
for a wedding
is it ain't right well yes i the
this did happen to me i don't know if
you remember i had planned i wasn't
engaged yet but
i had planned on um getting married at
this venue
which was very specific and um not
necessarily personal to me but
it was like a really i don't really have
original creative ideas and like it was
my own idea
and i made the mistake of telling
someone and that person
um literally texts me the next week that
they were gonna um that they visited and
that they're gonna get married there
and i was we didn't have a lot of
crossovers like i wasn't upset but it
was just like
okay steal my idea and then i actually
went to tour the place
and i really did not like the rain
option like it gives an outdoor venue
and it's like
it's so beautiful outdoor but if it
happens to rain if there's a cloud on
the radar you're getting married in a
rec hall
so it wasn't gonna work got it yeah
that's like
one level but this was just i'm sorry
didn't you say this [ __ ]
you guys like that just you're hanging
out with me too much no no but like
that's literally not the word
i meant to say that's so crazy i don't
whatever this
situation it just seems way more
personal
saint thomas is you know it's not just
20 minutes away like
right it's so much more orchestrated and
so
this is where this seems more similar to
stealing someone's baby name
yeah because it's so personal i would i
would talk to her and i would write out
before like what you want to say
why it makes you feel this way and be
prepared to lose a friendship and also
just make your wedding fun and a fun
wedding is not incumbent on money like i
can't stress that enough
it really is so much about the alcohol
and the band and the
alcohol banned people like as long as
you make sure that like the bar is
stocked
and the dance floor doesn't end and like
you have an after party and like
invite fun people like you'll be fine
it's not about money like literally
nobody cares about like
your programs are made of ivory like no
one [ __ ] cares nobody cares
okay next up and i wish i knew that when
i planned a wedding because i wasted
money on so much stuff
dear jackie and claudia first off i
wanted to thank you guys for the amazing
shows throughout the queue they have
been a lifesaver
thank you here's my situation my
boyfriend and i have been dating three
years he's the sweetest nicest and most
easygoing boyfriend we get along so well
and hardly fight
before the queue started after a long
day of drinking i hit up this girl who i
knew was kinda into me
we went out that night and then things
went further you can use your
imagination
i guess i identify as straight but my
friends who really know me
know that i tend to have crushes on
girls and make out with my friends when
i'm drunk sexuality is a spectrum
whatever the following morning i woke up
with the biggest pit i've ever had i
told my closest friends and they all
advised me that i tell my boyfriend what
happened
i saw him the next day thinking that i
would not tell him but the guilt was
overwhelming
i broke down and i told him what had
happened he asked for details but i told
him i wasn't ready to share just yet
i think i was just scared to say it out
loud he was pissed but not nearly as mad
as he could have been he did admit it
feels a little different because it's
happened with a girl rather than a guy
after this quick fairly calm chat he
said he didn't want to talk about it
anymore
it's been about five months and we
haven't spoken about it since that day
mind you i've been quarantining with my
boyfriend the entire time
i was obviously relieved that he wasn't
mad and wanted to drop it right away but
should i be worried that he didn't care
more
it's not like this girl is the one but i
clearly have some figuring out to do in
terms of my sexuality
i'm in my early 20s and i feel like this
is the time in my life i should be
figuring this stuff out but i do love my
boyfriend and i can't imagine breaking
up with him
any advice love a confused toaster you
know i feel like this is one of these
things where it's not either or i think
you can
be open and like why should you break up
with your boyfriend sounds like you have
a good relationship like
i think you can stay with your boyfriend
but you didn't do need to talk about
this like with yourself and with him and
he can be a part of this journey or not
you know yeah like
i think i agree with you it doesn't have
to be either or but whatever you decide
to do like your boyfriend needs to be on
board included in the decision and just
like
know what's going on i also feel like a
like a lot of guys would like this
yeah but he it seems like he is
conflicted about it because
he forgave you but doesn't want to talk
about it and maybe it's painful for him
um so i would i think communication is
the
is the answer here i actually think a
threesome is the answer here
but maybe we're a few steps behind that
just let him know how you're feeling
like and go through your thought process
with him and maybe
he might have some insights that will
make you or uh like
ideas that might make things
more clear to you so i definitely think
it's important to like
if you're feeling this way you should
pay attention to that
and not just be like don't ignore it
yeah don't ignore it don't ignore it i
mean we're not exactly call our daddy
but we're trying you know
threesome no but like communication i
think is is really what's best here
agreed but don't
um like sweep it under the rug because
this is something that'll keep coming up
because it's who you are so i would
get get in your feelings that's what the
q is for what else we do that is what
the q is for
all right next up and final dear jackie
and claudia my boyfriend
john and i have been dating for almost
three years this year i was invited on
john's family vacation in rhode island
with his parents
grandma's sister and her boyfriend
torture john and i had been fighting a
lot leading up to the trip and it really
came to a head on the saturday before we
were
leaving on sunday he said a lot of
horrible things along with the fact that
he wanted to break up
unfortunately this is a common
occurrence and i didn't know how much
stake to put in those words as we've
always worked things out and carried on
the relationship
i asked john if i should go on vacation
with his family and he said to go
he then later said he wasn't coming
again didn't know if i should believe
those words i mean he sounds like such a
drama queen
he was originally supposed to come for
the day sunday return home home to work
monday tuesday and rejoin us tuesday
night for the rest of the trip
he didn't come sunday at all again this
is his family yeah so she's out with his
family
i gave him two days alone and tried to
talk to him yesterday and he read my
texts and didn't respond
upon john's john's mom asking me what's
wrong i completely broke down and told
them everything
and how i felt so guilty that i was on
this vacation when we
maybe were actually broken up his
parents brushed it off said not to worry
john's dad has a very similar
personality so it's kind of a normal
thing for the men in the family to have
these long day mood swings
sounds like a tough family yeah because
of the tropical storm yesterday he
wasn't able to get here now it's
wednesday morning being today
well she's really writing us in real
time and john still hasn't talked to me
at all
well i feel like we can actually be
helpful yeah wait let's finish wait i
feel sad lonely and awful being here and
don't know how to proceed i don't want
to leave
and disrespect his parents who have been
so generous but is it wrong to stay what
do i do if he doesn't come at all signed
a toast or need of advice
you're like literally on vacation
technically with strangers
and you need to get out of there and
your boyfriend sounds honestly like
a nightmare like a piece of work
honestly if you
i think if you want to make the
relationship work and like you don't
plan on breaking up with him
you should stay and stick it out
actually i mean do whatever you want you
don't have to stay but like it might
make the thing bigger
but i don't even know but it doesn't
sound like but also maybe just enjoy
like the free vacation
it's hard though like it's hard it is
hard but
it doesn't sound like this is a great
relationship like he
obviously has communication issues and
doesn't know how to handle his emotions
and you seem extremely mature and like
you
deserve better and so i think it
shouldn't be on him to decide are we
broken up or are we not like you should
make that decision and if you want to be
broken up then make that call
and if you don't then have a really like
hard conversation with him where it's
like i see
i understand that maybe this is how your
family does things where you just go off
the grid and
people on vacation with strangers um but
that's not going to work for me and if
you want to be in
in this relationship things are going to
have to change i mean
i feel like there's potentially two
things going on here like one he could
just be really immature and learn from
his dad to like take a break for three
days when something upsets you
but that's not like a normal way of
handling things i feel like and if his
dad
has a two like it might be like uh some
sort of condition
like mental mental health wise and i'm
serious like you go off the grid for
three days nobody hears from you
i think it could be that and that's a
conversation worth having because this
is not
a an adult way of handling things you
know it's really not especially
when you going off the grid for three
days means
you being left alone with his family
like that makes no sense if you guys
were together and maybe not living
together and
you took like two days off just to cool
off
that's a little more decent but to leave
you alone with his family
it's honestly extremely selfish yeah and
i think you need to
start evaluating things not from like
what you did wrong and what you should
do yeah like
look at this person they're not treating
you the way that you deserve to be
treated
right and you're probably in that
mindset because that's how he makes you
feel but it's like at the end of the day
he's the upset one right you sound very
rational according to my notes and you
sound like a mature lovely person you
obviously have great taste in podcasts
and you seem nice because you're
sticking around with someone's family
when your boyfriend's not even there
you seem great it's not you according to
my paperwork
according to the paperwork it is not you
and you have the pit by the way the
paperwork doesn't lie no it does not lie
so you have a choice to make and i think
that you should
really think about it because
this isn't a normal situation no he
sounds like a real piece of work
yeah all right that was your toasters
again if you ever want to write in
please email us dear toasters
gmail.com always keep it anonymous
always keeping it real always keeping it
fresh
we need you we got you and that's all
she wrote anything else you want to say
before we wrap this baby up
no i think that that is all that she had
written thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we give
you the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast every
weekday monday through friday
on youtube we are also available as a
podcast and we're podcasts can be found
so it's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i have radio cast blocks all the
places
so wherever you listen to podcast find
us the morning toast and leave a five
star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we will see
you guys tomorrow on our thursday
episode we hope you have a fabulous day
[Music]
goodbye
you